il faut taper sur l'écran comporte que
ça fait 8 secondes à partir de
maintenant est ce chalenge les hyper
compliqué par contre personne va battre
ça c'est sûr je vais tout donner les
gars ça fait dix secondes
maintenant à savage pas très loin est ce
que tu as
[Musique]
il est 7 heures ça sent pas bon g20
message de flou je suis déjà dans la
voiture direction énergie aucun message
il est papier sur votre simple ça sent
la panne de réveil pour fo vois tu
regarderas cette vidéo certainement
vivait tout seul toujours pas de
nouvelles de flou il est pacsé sur
what's app je suis avec manu on va le
dégommer
sétois
[Musique]
je sens que je vais être éclaté on y va
ok c'est quoi qui donne tout ce que j'ai
tout va bien vers l'infini et l'au delà
ou continu continu c'est tout un autre
note
qu'est ce que c'est
qui
[Musique]